Alhamdulillah.
[Silence]
Continuing in the chapter of vigilance
of Allah's observation
of the fifth chapter of
authored
by half of al- Muadith Abu Zakaria
and Noi.
The 66th narration, the seventh
consecutive narration. Now, we have
touched on this narration before.
However, we will go ahead and review it
very quickly. He says,
Speech. Speech. Speech.
[Silence]
Does anybody remember anything about
this narration? This narration here is
on the authority of
in which it is narrated that the
prophet sallall.aii wasallam said the
intelligent person is the one who brings
himself to account and works for that
which comes after death.
And the true loser is the one who allows
his soul to follow whatever it desires
and then has the audacity to wish to
wish that Allah will do and give him on
top of that. This narration is collected
by Timothy. Do we remember this
narration?
Anyone? What do you remember about it?
Very
good. Mashallah. That is that the
meaning of the narration is correct.
However, the chain of narration is what
is weak. This chain of narration
contains in it a man
by the ka of
Abu Bakr ibiam
and Iban Abi Muriam is known to be a
weak narrator of hadith. Why?
It's not because he was a untrustworthy
person. To the contrary, very
trustworthy person. The problem is is
that his memorization
was not to the standards of
the scholars of hadith or the majority
of the scholars of hadith to where we
can rest assured
that his narration
on his own can be counted as acceptable
can be counted as authentic. Now the
meaning of the narration is correct
right for sure. For sure the meaning of
the narration is correct. Is this not
the theme of the Quran? The intelligent
listen to the words. The intelligent
are those who work for that which is
after death. Those who bring themselves
to account and work for that for after
for that which is after death.
And the true loser is the one who allows
his soul whatever it desires and then
wishes that Allah will do and give him.
Right? The meaning is correct. That sums
up the path of the believer. Correct?
However, here's an interesting point.
There is a difference between something
being correct and something being a
narration.
There is a difference between something
being
in its in itself the meaning being
correct and something being
something being
appropriate to be the words of the
prophet sallall.aii wasallam. This is a
principle of the science of hadith. I
hope that you all will memorize it
because it will help you a lot.
The principle is
saiam.
The principle tells us that not all
correct or good statements are fit to be
the words of the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam. Just because something is
correct, just because something has a
good meaning, just because something
fits does not mean that it is fit to be
the words of the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam. Because for something to be
the words of our prophet Muhammad
sallall.aii alaihi wasallam. It has a
very strict
set of parameters that it has to fit,
conditions that it has to fulfill in
order for us to have the audacity to say
our prophet said such and such saiam.
In order for us to say the messenger of
Allah
did, said, accepted, acknowledged,
confirmed. In order for us to make that
statement,
we have to be mostly sure
almost almost
you know to the to the level that is
beyond a shadow of a doubt or beyond a
reasonable doubt that our prophet
sallall.aii alaihi wasallam said this.
Notice the wording beyond a reasonable
doubt. What is beyond a reasonable
doubt? When you go to the pharmacy and
you have a prescription, you give it to
the, you know, pharmacist. Pharmacist
says, "Go ahead and take a seat. I'll
get that ready for you." Then he brings
you the prescription.
From the moment you take the
prescription from the pharmacist to when
you take the first dose to when you take
the last dose. How many of us
are absolutely
100%
without
an unreasonable doubt sure
that this is exactly the correct
medicine that we have to take?
What if we had to live our lives like
that? Imagine that. Human being is
innately ignorant, right?
Imagine if we had to live our lives like
that.
Is it possible that the doctor made a
mistake? He's thinking about something
going on at home. He made a mistake. He
wrote down, jotted down the wrong
medicine on the prescription. Is that
possible? Is it possible that the doctor
made a mistake in
diagnostics?
He diagnosed me with the wrong thing. Is
that possible? Is it possible
that, and you guys have seen this, that
a lot of times the doctor doesn't always
write the prescription. It's written for
him, right? It's printed out now. You go
get it. Is it possible that the nurse at
the front, she's getting married soon
and she's picking out wedding dresses
and she's thinking about other stuff,
gives you the wrong prescription, gives
you the prescription of the medicine
that will kill you instead of healing
you. Is that possible? When you go take
that prescription over to the
pharmacist,
is it possible that the pharmacist is
thinking about something else and grabs
the wrong medicine? Is it possible he
reaches up and grabs the wrong bottle
right next to the bottle of medicine and
instead grabs a bottle to you, which is
poison? Is it possible
that the bottles get mixed up? Is it
possible? Think about how many places in
that simple process.
How many things could have gone wrong
from the moment you re go to the doctor
until the moment you put that powerful
pharmaceutical into your body?
Yet, how much research
do we do? We do enough
to where it's reasonable, but thousands
of people die every single year in
America because of mishaps and
prescriptions.
Either the doctor's handwriting isn't
legible or the pharmacist gives the
wrong prescription or the wrong dosage
is is written on the thing every single
year.
However,
if we were to live our life with beyond
a shadow of a doubt
or even if we were to just live our
lives with beyond a reasonable doubt,
right? And everything we did, we would
essentially be paralyzed. We wouldn't we
wouldn't be able to do anything. We
wouldn't get anything done. So we
innately have to rely on each other in
order to function in society.
The conditions
the criteria for an authentic narration
is far higher
than the criteria for that medicine that
you take and put into your body from the
pharmacist. It is far higher than the
criteria
for a per for that doctor to have gotten
his medical license. It is far higher
than the criteria for that pharmacist to
have graduated and gotten his
pharmaceutical license. It is far
higher. the threat the the the
conditions for an authentic narration
are far superior to the conditions for
all of that and rightfully so because if
one prescription is messed up one person
might die. However, if one narration
is confused,
millions, billions, generations of
Muslims will
perhaps adopt a misguidance.
So the words of the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam have an extremely high level of
criteria in order to be met amongst the
scholars of hadith. in order for a
narration to be considered what?
Acceptable. Just acceptable. Authentic.
And then there are levels of
authenticity on top of that.
So it's important for us to realize that
when our scholars
tell us this narration is inauthentic or
this narration is authentic, this
doesn't just come about because
you know just taking a guess at things
just you know
just just it's it's just guess work or
it's just I think so it sounds Good.
Sounds all right. Nothing glaringly
obvious about it. Let it through. That
is not how the science of hadith works.
And one of the biggest things that we
are challenged with today as Muslim in
this time in this generation in this
place that we are living is the attack
against our books of hadith our books of
the prophet sallall.aii alaihi
wasallam's tradition.
And a lot of times the arguments that
are brought up are so purile and
unreasonable,
so purile and ridiculous that anyone who
has even dabbled casually in the science
of hadith would laugh at. They're not
real shoo. They're not real
issues of consideration that are brought
up. But what are we suffering from? We
are suffering from an ailment that Allah
subhanahu wa'ta'ala tells us.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala tells us the
methodology
the hermeneutics
so to speak the sciences of the
disbeliever and his disbelief and
rejection of the Quran. He tells us they
reject what they have not fully
understood, what they have not fully
what they have not fully studied and
they have not yet received its full
understanding and its full
explanation.
There is a very important principle that
we want to end with and that is very
simple statement. It sounds
it is common sense, but as they
say, common sense is not so common.
And that is
learn before you object. A person comes
and says, I disagree.
Disagreement needs to come from a place
of knowledge.
You don't just disagree with something
that you haven't understood, that you
haven't researched, that you haven't
studied.
In order to
object to something, you need to have
studied it to its end
or have a clearcut evidence that it is
falsehood.
Right? So for instance we have evidence
that
Adam was created by Allah correct he was
created from dirt fashioned and then a
life was put into him. Someone comes and
says no he he evolved from animals and
apes and then became can we reject this
immediately? Do we have to study biology
and modern Darwinian evolution with all
of its contraptions
and all of its conceptualized,
you know, contraptions in order
for us to reject this? No. someone
comes along and says
you know accuses
of being unfaithful. Do we need to study
their argument all the way to its end
before we reject it? No. Right? Because
immediately we have clear evidence from
Allah and his messenger that this is
rejected immediately. Someone comes and
claims to be Allah.
Someone comes and claims to be.
Someone comes and cla
emerges.
Do we have to study his med and listen
to all his speeches to make sure that we
he is not truly?
No. Because we have what Sultan we have
evidence that is clearcut from Allah and
his messenger. However,
when it comes to things such as the
science of hadith, such as you cannot
just take something that the scholars of
Islam have said, scholars of Islam has
have explained, have used as evidence
from the Quran and Sunnah, and then just
dismiss it off the cuff without
understanding it. and then dismissing it
with understanding and knowledge that is
very different.
These two things are very different
things. And so the first principle we
took today is
what is it?
not every
acceptable statement is accepted and fit
to be the words of the prophet.
Remember that it's going to help you in
your life. Number two,
the second is
and
learn
before you object. When you object, you
object based on what? Based on
knowledge.
Learn before you object. So that when
you object to something, say I disagree.
It's disagreement that comes from
knowledge, not just novelty.